les réactions sont nombreuses au
lendemain de nos révélations sur l'état
de délabrement du pont mercier on vous
disait ya que la structure aura besoin
de réflexion majeur au cours des
prochaines années ça pourrait même aller
jusqu'à la reconstruction pure et simple
jean-sébastien cloutier
à la queue leu leu pour prendre le pont
mercier la scène était plutôt habituel
ce matin à sainte catherine aussi
habituel qu'une annonce sur le mauvais
état du pont champlain qui au mieux puis
moi je travaille avec ça l'aurait fait
que c'est comme le seul chemin que j'ai
pour y aller le plus banal encore 3g
mais on n'a pas le choix quand on
commence tôt le matin ça vaut consistera
fais un peu partout poussent à ce propos
pratique pour les travailleurs du québec
devra t-il aller jusqu à reconstruire la
partie originale du pont mercier
trop tôt pour le dire en attendant le
nouveau ministre des transports veut
rassurer le précédent gouvernement
remplacé des gens sur le pont mercier
sur une base quotidienne font l'analyse
l'évaluation de la sécurité et la
réparation du pont et une deuxième un
deuxième consortium qui valide le
travail justement sur le pont mercier et
en 2015 on va voir l'emploi des
réparations qu'on doit faire donc on va
réparer pour mercy et d'ici là le pont
mercier sécurité selon ce professeur
spécialisé en transport le gouvernement
n'aura pas le choix de refaire un
nouveau pont la faute aux élus
provinciaux qui se sont succédé ces
catastrophes qui est que tous les
suisses avaient venir c'est tout ce que
québec s'occupera de son dossier québec
le fil sur plus tard plus tard toujours
plus tard et puis bien sûr on gère à la
catastrophe comme bien les dossiers
montréalais malheureusement des mères ou
si on réagit à notre reportage les
problèmes d'alima jean pied de port par
rapport à ce dossier là on doit pas être
alarmiste non plus parce qu'il ya toute
la question de la sécurité je pense
qu'un port impôts mise en doute on voit
demain on va demander des rapports et
évidemment c'est beaucoup de
découragement on est
on on est toujours dans l'espoir que ça
va se terminer puis finalement à chaque
fois que les nouvelles arrivent c'est de
mal en pis sur la rive-sud bien des
cyclistes sont déçus eux aussi ils
auront une piste cyclable qui n'ira pas
plus loin que le milieu du pont tant que
québec ne refera pas sa partie
on demande pas si cela m'a pas vu une
île je n'ai pas les coûts exacts sera
intéressant d'explorer ça mais c'est
dommage c'est un autre ces raisons
qu'ils passent un autre nid qui passe le
vélo devient de plus en plus populaire
tout le monde c'est une belle
alternative mais vous nous avez montré
cette image l'agencé bastia de cette
paix cyclable qui arrive est nulle part
bon et parlant des gros travaux ils sont
pas vraiment commencé mais des gens
dépensent plusieurs millions ouais des
chiffres de juin ont confirmé en fin
d'après-midi par le cabinet du ministre
des transports à québec pour la période
2013 à 2015 patrice québec a alloué 15
millions de dollars à des firmes de
génie pour étudier l'état de la
structure décidé quoi en faire et
effectuer des travaux de maintien de
cette structure est un autre 15 millions
pour valider et surveiller les premières
firmes bref 30 millions en tout et ça ça
exclut les millions qui ont été dépensés
pour les travaux d'urgence en 2011 bref
un autre exemple comme quoi c'est anissi
les ponts vers la rive sud sont de
véritables gouffres financiers pour les
gouvernements particulier le
gouvernement du québec
en terminant je vous signale que demain
une rencontre entre des représentants de
québec et ottawa avec les maires
plusieurs maires de la rive sud
il sera notamment question de l'état des
travaux sur le pont champlain
attendons nous à bien des questions de
leur part puis vous allez est occupée au
cours des prochains mois jean sébastien
parce que le dossier vous nous aviez
préparé sur le slr on va reparler un peu
plus tard dans l'émission là à québec on
a reparlé de ce à montréal également il
ya un autre salaire celui dont vous nous
aviez parle également dans l'ouest de
l'île de montréal deux projets de slr
distincts donc voilà on suit la merci au
revoir au revoir